takes the seat belt off this is all and
decides and I'm like I'm just like
taking the
you know what I'm saying and you don't
say and my brother's in the backseat and
I just see him like go like
[Laughter]
[Music]
you guys ever had a grandma who like
would slap you or like hit you for being
bad nope nope really my grandma and
grandpa were so [ __ ] cute that the
one time my grandpa [ __ ] slow motion
slapped me oh so Junior High I was uh
yeah Junior High I was I went to go
visit Taiwan and you know like you're in
a rebellious face so I got into it with
my mom's little sister
which is my aunt and she's older and uh
we were like yelling back and forth I
took a remote and I chucked it at the TV
and then my grandpa like was reading a
newspaper
and he like with his [ __ ] glasses and
he saw me he was so pissed
like this
and he went [ __ ] came over all slow
he was like
like that and I was like oh
that loves me never slapped me I feel so
bad like I'm like for him to do that
that means I [ __ ] up you know and it
wasn't it was like that it was a tab
like that but it was just slow oh wow it
took like six months to get there too I
was like yeah and I was just like lofty
speed [ __ ] up I was like damn I
[ __ ] disrespected like in Asian
culture not only my Elder which you're
not you're never supposed to do that
right but also his daughter and I was
like oh [ __ ] my uh family members told
me my grandma [ __ ] me up but I have no
memory of it
[ __ ] she [ __ ] the memory out of my
head bro no I just remember dope ass
memories like she took me to the park we
would go to the grocery store like I
didn't remember none of that oh she beat
you up a good time so it's like your
dad's memory of beating you basically
but I forgot that she passed down in the
chromosome he's like Joe what do you
mean we only have dope ass memories
together what if what if I twisted the
memory and my dad didn't [ __ ] me up my
grandma did but I played my [ __ ] dad
dude that's like shutter Islands I know
right I'm definitely it's like Fight
Club your grandma's chocolate uh oh yeah
sure from your grandma oh yeah yeah uh
or or uh Korea or the belch okay that's
the worst she's ever the belt she would
uh she would get the belt but it would
just be scary because she would get it
but she would just like smack the door
frame I could make that loud like pop
damn that's scary one of those like get
you know like and you have to go past
her so that's the thing where you're
like like that was it was she like mini
golf with a mine
yeah psychological battle here yeah that
um a wood spoon that she's like cooking
with yeah
you know
grandma was disciplining you did it ever
occur to you to fight back hell no no no
no you wanted a soccer huh no no no no
that's too scary yeah well it's just we
got a special one here in China then oh
[ __ ] so this right this is a big it's a
big big story because a lot of JK people
have been sending it to the account
being like yo cover this cover oh wow
thank you guys for sending it yeah thank
you guys
um so in China a 10 year old boy who's
being disciplined by his grandma ends up
fighting back
he uh this is all in video by the way
which We're not gonna watch he why he
puts you in the headlock he puts his
ground in headlock and he keeps telling
her like you always hit me why you
always hit me oh he's snapping you're
telling me I'm unreasonable and there's
a like some I guess like another family
member's just filming it and like his
little sister that wouldn't stop it
someone's filming it and they're just
saying stop it stop and he's just like
it got her to headlock like she's picked
up a slipper and just like hitting him
she's like and then slowly it just
becomes oh no he chokes her yeah it
talks her out to death no
death bro oh he's 10 right he's 10 years
old who the [ __ ] was recording 10 years
old not only that but another another
lady comes in with like a kid on her
back and she's like you killed her and
she's like started slowly
it is some like and then he puts her in
a headlock too and then the kid the
little 10 year old like realizes what
he's done and he's just like trying Cry
he's like get up Grandma oh that's so
sad yeah well he's 10 10 years old at
that age you're fighting for your life
how big is this [ __ ] it's like
David size 10 year old or what dude he
looks like a 10 year old how old is the
Grandma
she's a four foot Chinese Grandma yeah
who is recording that's that's crazy
dude yeah so whoever was recording I
don't know if it was a family member
because this situation like once it kind
of got traction there was more info uh
the boy was living with his grandma
while his parents were out of town like
they go on like overseas business so
it's just him and the grandma
so after she's dead he doesn't have a
care like a caretaker around the boy got
arrested yeah that's sad damn man 10
years old dude what did they do for uh
kids in China like when they go to jail
do they have a juvie or anything like
that I don't know anything did I just go
to regular they're gonna [ __ ] him up
though dude they sent him to North Korea
oh [ __ ] yeah trade relations yeah the um
it's it's crazy because like this was
all over uh it was like viral in China
like on weibo and everything and damn
and then um yeah it I guess it kind of
got said that the little boy like he had
friends that were around that were
egging them on to fight back to his
grandma oh yeah but that's that's not
their fault it's still the though it's
not but it's uh it just it just reeks of
like little poor Village kind of yeah
and at 10 years old you don't really
know what murder like you don't think
you're gonna kill somebody
by wrestling moves yeah yeah yeah
choking them out I thought I thought
maybe he like choked her out like like
put her to sleep you know like where
she'll end up like coming back up yeah
then usually what happens right yeah in
a headlock well I mean maybe it's a
grandma that I sleeper I mean he just
had her so long that it's like yo she's
gonna be the circulation you should have
stopped hitting him she did nothing too
she was like she eventually did and he
was still just like oh he was like
saying his piece you know like he's like
telling her all this [ __ ] like finally
that's what I was thinking like he
probably like literally snapped blacked
out on a on a
um like maybe maybe she was abusing him
uh you know like awesome like you know
what this is fine like he's getting his
he didn't think he was gonna kill it
though I think it's wrong that he did
that but at the same time it's like dude
that's her karma for like treating
somebody this way too you know damn you
ruthless dog no because it always comes
back it always comes back to you in some
way it may it would suck that it was the
boy that did it to her you're a yin yang
dude I don't know I think yeah I don't
know maybe if she is or maybe she's not
yeah we don't see Grandma yeah or she's
just like a regular Chinese average
grandma that will beat your ass like
maybe she was disciplining him and he's
just like you keep abusing me yeah you
know what I mean like you just you just
don't [ __ ] know like how severe well
yeah what made him in the moment like
it's even on video that she's hitting
him over something he was doing already
so she's like like just like like
already kind of swatting at him and then
he just like snaps and just like whoever
pulls her down and he's just like
holding it like dude what I also see is
like the the maybe because the parents
are always gone he never had that love
so he's kind of like ah I'm an angry
child and I always you know like there's
no love towards me so I'm just gonna be
hateful oh 100 dude I think I was pretty
capable of
um doing violence against
like adults my parents anybody your
grandmother your grandpa not my
grandparents because I think well for
for one when my mom disciplined me
um it was always
there was always parameters she never
hit me out of just
um or impulse yeah it was always you
[ __ ] up this is the things that you
did you did this wrong so you're gonna
get this many spankings uh for my
grandma I just don't remember but then I
do remember like if it was my dad or my
brother or something like that my uncle
it was always impulsive always pointless
there was no explanation so it just felt
like an outright fight so then in those
cases I always thought I can't wait till
I get bigger I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
and it wasn't even I'll fight you I
pulled out I pulled out a knife on my
dad and then I tried to slice his ass up
and I was like nine or some [ __ ] and
then he basically kicked it out of my
hand you know
karate Roundhouse
but I mean like
it's like it's like you know when you're
that age like in my head I was like I'm
gonna [ __ ] murder you like stop
hitting me but then but then he's
probably like look at this little piece
of [ __ ] you know it's like a 300 kick me
and just [ __ ] yeah exactly like you
stupid idiot I tried standing up to my
dad it was actually just through text so
I really wasn't even they wouldn't even
asked to ask you hit it with the all
caps but exclamation points emojis I
actually just learned this word I I
learned the word ignorant like my my
mentor was like we're putting me on game
of like you know some people are just
ignorant they just know he broke it down
to me and I was like that's my dad and I
waited and I waited for the the perfect
moment he was kind of like you know he
was antagonizing my mom this was like
during like divorce you know uh times
and all this shit's actually really
heated it's like yeah yeah yeah perfect
he was like you know antagonizing a bit
and so I went with like this was like
through the phone so it was kind of like
you know leaving some nasty voicemails
and stuff so I text my Dad we're at the
mall and I was like yo Pops leave mom
alone you're being ignorant right yeah
this was grown up yeah yeah upset like
yeah yeah and he called me right away
and he goes where you at and I'm like
I'm at the mall he's like I'll pull up
over there right now you want to talk to
me like an adult like we can go like
what's like out like you like he
basically just broke it down to me of
like like rub me my fade and I was like
I was just saying that you have to like
leave mom alone like mom's trying to
like get his shoes and you're
and she's like that funny thing she's
like sad and he's like I don't give up
like he was just like yo like what's
like you you don't ever talk to me like
that and it's that like and yo I didn't
even get to have the moment of like
standing up to my dad like you know
leave him alone type of thing I it was
it was like I just it was through text
and he a phone call scared the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] no yeah I was just like I think I
remember get off the phone I was just
like you're like
I got the phone and I was kind of like I
was kind of like mad at like like at my
mom a little bit and I was like
I stood up for you all right I tried it
I was like I tried to and you made me
look ignorant
was was whoopings from your dad scary
I've gotten one ultimate whooping from
my dad and I think he even knew that
after that he's gonna pull back oh like
the [ __ ] it wasn't like it wasn't
closed Vista he gave me an ultimate
spanking that was like on the bus right
but it was like it was like a Super
Saiyan like like you know like hadouken
and like over and over and off yeah yeah
yeah and it was uh it was in the in the
in the back seat of of the Jeep right
like uh yeah the same Jeep you were
driving
it was uh it was because of uh we went
to the uh the Star Wars convention like
it was a museum and it had a Star Wars
exhibit right and uh of the souvenir
shop was the last thing like we're gonna
go through the exhibit and then we're
going to souvenir shop and of course
what do you want out of the Star Wars
[ __ ] lightsaber and a cloak that's it
you know I just wanted the Lifesaver you
know yeah and so I knew the exactly I
found it it was the one where the light
would actually go up it would just like
turn on
the whole thing noises all that [ __ ] my
dad's like sticker book I'm like a
sticker book and it was it was a book
where it was like you get the it was all
just scenes from the Star Wars
you get to put the make the scenes with
the sticker book
oh I was like hey yo I was like oh and I
was so sure I was pops I'm 22.
yo I was like I just remembered like I
just I told him like he was like going
to the checkout this whole thing I'm
like yo like I got the lightsaber he's
like go put that back and I'm like no
like I I want the lightsaber you know
and and and I was so I was just be I was
being ignorant I was just being a little
[ __ ] little troll I was like you can
get the book I'm not gonna use it I'm
not you can buy it okay yeah you know
but I'm not gonna use it
I'm using light sir and it's making all
the noises you can get the you can get
them
but I'm not gonna use it you know you
know and my dad's just like doing that
like wait till we get to the car wait
till they're like all right you know and
he's looking at the other families
right he's still smiling his his way out
of this whole thing and my dad played it
so cool yo like when we got to the car I
was I was thinking like I was like okay
like and he put on music and you know my
brother's in the front seat and he
played we drove for a bit that like oh
he forgot like my dad made it seem like
it was just nothing like that didn't
happen it was all good I was like I'm
gonna get away with this and I just
remember like we we like he took an exit
that ain't the exit to our crib oh my
God he went into a neighborhood that is
in our neighborhood
and like he like punched the brakes out
of at a at a stop sign like a and he and
he he goes around and he's coming around
to me and I was it it was y'all was like
so slow motion y'all I guess it's so
very he opens the door and just like in
one motion like puts me like down like
this takes the seat belt off and so and
just starts and I'm like I'm just like
taking it
and my brother's in the backseat and I
just see him like go like
[Laughter]
you know he's looking at something I'm
just like I'm like help what if your dad
put the stickers on his hand yeah
oh my God so you gonna make the scene
now boy
yeah yeah it was the it was that and
then like he got back to the car and
like you know went to go driving he was
just saying like you'll never disrespect
me again like like that you know this is
mad and like went back home and I had to
uh like he I got sent to my room I had
to write you know I'll never disrespect
my dad like like uh on like three pages
front and back he gave me like he gave
me like some you know he disciplined you
yeah yeah
yeah yeah part of me makes me feel like
I'm so stupid because I never learned my
lesson after beatings like that over and
over yeah yeah for sure I learned that
one that one was that one yeah and that
was his last spay like he never spanned
any of us like that was the one that was
just like we all know so your brother
saw and that became a legend that was a
threshold you only had to do it once
then yeah that's nice one one good one
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah
and then every Christmas after that you
got Star Wars stickers just to remind us
how about this year
[Music]
[Music]